herr linder hallo ich will selbst bauer
werden
haben sie irgendwelche tipps für mich
was muss ich da machen ich glaube als
bauer brauchen sie erst mal eine
berufsausbildung das ist nämlich nicht
was man so eben so macht wie im garten
sondern aber auch mal eine ordentliche
berufsausbildung in ehrlichen beruf also
anders als wir beide schon sagen er
politiker muss man wirklich was kann ja
das ist selbstkritisch das ist nicht gut
ja lächerlich und wollen sie den
landwirt egal hauptsache weg vom
fernsehen egal müssen sie auf öko machen
dann haben sie die meiste arbeit und den
gerichten verdienst
wieso das denn
wie komme ich dann das geld welches geld
ich will ja selber auch geflügel bauer
werden könnten sie mir jetzt mal zeigen
die man also ein küken professionell
schreddert wir schreiten solche küche
nicht ich dachte die werden heutzutage
werden die menschen nicht geschreddert
und deutschen händen gekommen die es
lange dem zoo damit die zuschauer können
sie ja einfach werden kommen sie auch
nicht mehr stellen sie sich mal vor was
sie so machen
sein name ist daniela schulz ich bin im
bundesumweltministerium schulze wie
schulz schulz & schulz durch kein gutes
oben erstmal doch klar heißen viele ist
ein beliebter name ich will selbst bauer
werden
haben sie eine idee wie ich das nach
aktuellem wissensstand mache um
möglichst viele fördergelder abzugreifen
muss der betrieb möglichst groß und
möglichst asozial sollen
na ja im moment gibt es die fördergelder
der eu vor allen dingen wenn man viel
fläche hat also es wäre ganz gut wenn
sie viele flächen haben auf dem sie dann
landwirtschaft betreiben und dass das
genau das was ich falsch findet
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was ist das denn jetzt hier dass sie
eine wirkung auf kurse gerät für diese
floralen konzentration da wären die
vergabe kastriert werden
was gemacht wird ja gerne gerne das werk
in der bucht so weg drückt ihr verein
macht so zu dann geht so fest ja und man
kann hoffen lassen zum fixieren
das ist schön sieht sie schon so weg
dass man schon in kraft treten kann wie
hier auf dem film sehen dann kommt die
grüne lampe zu hören nicht nur nicht
jetzt
sie hat nichts passiert nicht drücken
sie nicht den grünen knopf hinterher
verhinderung da haben wir sind der
erfinder von der förder kastrations-
maschine hätte ich jetzt eher gedacht
das ist eine frau erfindet zu einer
kastration es ist eine fantastische
karriere von der weinkönigin zu schwein
königin
das haben sie sachen beschluss ich bin
auch im schweizer business tätig ich
habe auch abitur ein führerschein baku
also ich muss ich noch mal ein
kompliment machen sie haben ja gezeigt
was für einem freien land wir leben in
einem land in dem man schweine ohne
betäubung kastrieren kann zwei jahre
lang noch fantastisch das wird sich
ändern und ich sage ihnen dadurch dass
ich jetzt etwas auf den weg gebracht hat
was verhindert gehabt dass wir jetzt die
isofluran verordnung da geht es um eine
vollnarkose und wir werden am ende
dieser zwei jahre weiter sein als alle
anderen europäischen länder
ok jetzt haben sie es nicht mehr
erzählen sie den völkern das sind die
armen schweine noch mal es geht darum
dass wir zum beispiel auch bei meinem
tier wohl kennzeichen das sich
entwickelt da wird eine betäubungslose
ferkelkastration nicht möglich sein das
heißt wenn sie fleisch kaufen mit einem
tier wohl kennzeichen dann ist das
fleisch von nicht betäubungslos
kastrierten schweinen also ist dann
nicht von den
das tut man zealand herald land mehr als
schöne frau interessieren sich nicht für
mich aus schlecht müssen wir schauen wie
sie anderen besitz kommen also
einheiraten man sie zum beispiel heirate
ich eine reiche bäuerin werden die idee
haben sie kontaktdaten wenn ich die
hätte richtig geht
[Musik]
klickt hier für weitere heute schon
videos und clips moment
und klickt hier um den channel zu
abonnieren
[Musik]